[Music]  my diesel wants you somebody help you  this alright just a bear  I'll get it thanks man can you help me  this tool  oh thanks man hey do it let me put a pic  bum in so we're there  well is there Oh hold on thanks man no  problem  dinner is sweet McIntyre no I don't  leave me enough of my DNA what I have  job no did you know this did you you I  talking about  no no I get it it's fine I'll live  a few moments later  so romantic and so glad I owe you my you  know bit thank you for pouring sometimes  this can help you this too what is this  [Music]  dude doing it visit me and I already see  enough yes I know you I know yes you  should you too okay your old room  hello okay thanks bye